hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry
Jerry and I are gonna watch today
something that I was like comments are
gonna go in here for requests for Star
Wars Episode four honest trailers oh boy
let's do this now I know I said Episode
four some people gonna be like it's just
called Star Wars no it's called Star
Wars and you help let's not argue about
this you know which movie it's the same
like honest trailers from your once
masterful director who just couldn't
leave well enough alone I've got a
special effects blockbuster that
transformed the entire film industry
into an assembly line for special
effects blockbusters and action figures
story
yep the first one we are not calling it
a new hope right along with some of
film's most iconic characters surrounded
by films most iconic props and designs
in some of the most iconic locations
ever to the point where every single
person place or thing on screen as it
least a 1000 word Wikipedia article
about you know these guys are called
jizz Whalers
Whalers be heroes yes
Princess Leia finds interesting of the
two human females in the entire movie
han Solo a real Han Solo ty every1
a wise Jedi Master who doesn't remember
the joy that saved his life several
times him to remember the meal enjoy the
drool all beings with feelings and free
will who were bought and sold as slaves
you think that melted down please don't
deactivate me
hashtag droid lives matter guys and Luke
Skywalker a whiny space brat watashi
station to pick up some power converters
hmm kinda reminds me of self
one it's all OB ones false but there's
nothing I can do about it right now I
hate them but their backyard is not fair
it just isn't fair
wait so Hayden Christensen's acting
choices were intentional whoa my blood
now most epic space just as I all-time
that would have been totally unnecessary
if anyone had email I've placed
information vital to the survival of the
rebellion into the memory systems of
this r2 unit to take on the evil empire
with an army of clumsy idiots led by the
most threatening villain of all time
Darth Vader until you hear his original
voice tear this in apart piece by piece
you have no case cutting the passengers
in this vessel I want them in life never
heard that not so epic now are you bro
return to a time when technology force
George Lucas to collaborate with other
people as ETS of the masses sound design
school and and practical visual effects
to deliver a near-perfect movie that
he's made progressively worse with each
special edition because if there's one
thing the original Star Wars wasn't
missing its poorly rendered how to play
CGI animals filling up every square into
the bright dude
come on we're out of the way I can't
even see the movie we live all the parts
your massager goggles keep you from
admitting what kind of dumb why this guy
a bargain bin werewolf mask the
lightsaber battle we're two old geezers
gently poke at each other and the most
over-the-top Freudian finale of all time
Lucas the possible pilot we had a Rim
territories
would be able to penetrate the outer
defense been going look at that speed
with david flood in time that's what she
said yeah so whether you're an old man
who can't move on from a 38 year old
movie for children or a contrarian kid
who thinks he's being edgy when he says
the prequels were better one thing is
for sure
han shot first star and sky walkers in
flight you beats my brave star ford
genuine class dog is my co-pilot
Ouiser Porkins oh that's just mean and
Oscar into trash can sing blue milk and
Nazis in space yeah just a storm
yeah as well as the only real lightsaber
let's be realistic we cut off our own
hand in a week the screen junkies you
know and love just got bigger
and we saved our biggest surprise for
last hey no way it's coming no way play
with it right here explosively 300-plus
whoa
how do we score them screen junkies plus
starring over a dozen new shows between
your bed oh wow why we'll be in TV
fights each and every week on its
trailer commentaries between bonus jokes
and behind the scenes info interactive
programming starring you the viewer
exclusive invitations to special events
and screen junkies meetups across the
country and our first original scripted
series interns of field hahaha and do we
mention that we got Jay and Silent Bob
cuz we totally did screen junkies
applause start your three-month free
trial now at screen junkies calm damn
I'm down for that or do not get there
now to try on
I like doorknobs you're a hairy wizard
you are a natural
a natural disaster you shall not wait
what was the line where we got her to
see that screen junkies [ __ ] again beds
we all want to of just God bigger
and we saved our biggest surprise for
last hey did they get sense coming
that's right you can see us coming every
week man's me unlock the place
whoa how do we score that I'm boxing
video measurements applause story over a
dozen new show
Jeremy John for Donna remedies love
black nerd knocking off each and every
week
on its trailer commentaries between
bonus jokes and behind the scenes info
interactive programming strong efforts
of unisys exclusive invitations to
special events and screen junkies
meetups across the country and our first
original scripted series interns of
field oh and did we mention that we got
Jay and Silent Bob cuz we totally did
screen junkies applause I'm so happy for
them that they're doing that place it
started off on YouTube and now they're
branching out into something even
crazier and bigger they have a lot of
respected personalities on board you
know a scripted series now like that's
pretty [ __ ] neat like it sounds like
it's worth the pain whatever the monthly
subscription is yeah I mean that like
this is the cutting edge of at least the
gap between new media internet stuff and
TV this is like yeah no one seems to be
able to figure out because it's so new
and it looks like they're getting to try
the next step up and then the next step
from there's television you know if they
want to go in a TV I'm I'm sure by now
they could go in at eat what they wanted
to TV is shifting towards the internet
with things like streaming and your
binge watching and stuff like that and
it seems like the Internet is sort of
shifting it seems like they're gonna
meet in the middle
and this is part of that it sounds so
exciting they got Jay and Silent Bob Bob
or I could see how they got Kevin Smith
on board oh yeah I mean he's like he
loves you if he was just making it so
she's gonna be making half of this
content yeah exactly and to get those
two big stars to be able to do unboxing
videos you guys are in competition with
me now but for the once a month unboxing
videos idea better bucks something I
would show you what's in my super geek
box but
moved all the collectables somewhere
else and I replaced it with a lot of
bottles and stuff just tiny potions you
call them potions yeah well they change
your mood and they gave you a little
hungry
it's like Alice in Wonderland yeah with
a little bit more she'll there's stuff
to grind it to to make it easier to you
know whatever oh I see I see I see the
spice rack in the Star Wars video itself
the other than screen junkies the joke I
really liked was Joseph Campbell's Star
Wars well I mean and he is like talk so
openly about like how it hears of a
Thousand Faces from this one interview I
saw really loving the mythology and they
want to recreate it and Star Wars um but
it is exactly is exactly that it is
exactly that and it set the template as
they put an F for ya hundreds and
hundreds of you know big blockbuster
movie
oh yeah deed looks like like half of all
action movies are probably even more
than that are the hero's journey just
with different [ __ ] exactly exactly and
I don't know the history of the Star
Wars I feel like I've heard stuff about
it but a Darth Vader's voice was that
supposed to be the original voice or did
they always have the UH
oh my god what's his name James Oh John
James Earl Jones James Earl Jones good
thing I didn't ask you what's a big
black guy's thing that would have been
embarrassing
I don't know I didn't realize but I
guess it makes sense it maybe I would
have been horrible did they put in his
voice later that would have been
horrible what if they did that actual
voice this one yeah well it makes it
look more like a like a sci-fi show you
would have seen on the BBC yeah
it's reaching a little too high so it's
a little bit silly but it's alright I
just can't remember if they always like
if they had the actor who was in the
suit just do the dialogue on set and
they knew they would replace it later or
if they heard it and then went on should
we go yeah if that's the case sorry for
that guy but it had to be done Hayden
Christensen and Mark Hamill's acting
Mark Hamill is like a little over the
top is whiny well he's like worried but
you know he's I like him though he's
acting a little too much of an in a
really honest way yeah there's a level
of innocence
to him that's kind of like a 1950's
black-and-white TV show but Hayden
Christensen I could see that some way it
was probably intentional where he's like
well this is how Mark Hamill was again
he's the father of Mark Hamill so I
could see how he might have chosen that
however Hayden Christensen annoyed the
[ __ ] out of me he did yeah yeah if you
look as I recall anyway the Star Wars
prequel is if you look all around there
are lots of good actors who give kind of
stilted or kind of wooden performances
or you know with that sort of naive tone
of voice that you know older actors had
but like I've seen you and McGregor be
better in things so I feel like the
whole acting is sort of supposed to be
in the style of Star Wars acting yeah
cuz like start Lee acting as Star Wars
isn't
terrific but the nuances are right so
the performances are still good let's
face it still like a little bit wooden
but it's great I gotta go back into our
star earliest p.m. ever you watch all
six and do reviews for them on this
channel
oh yeah that's a guy yeah I figure you
know likes the new Star Wars is coming
out so be a great time for real and use
you know based off of the fact like it's
marketing it's a revealing here or
moderating here session you know and
then I like put the video out of them
like hey for you guys I decided to do
this but really it's just a really
clever marketing decision yeah the
finished I was like hey I kind of came
out of the prequels being like I wonder
if the acting is supposed to be that way
just cuz it's like not great except this
time it's just not great yeah yeah like
I can't believe they would act that way
unless it was intentional for a lot of
them anyway well maybe the justification
was was that it's a prequel in the
originals the acting was good so the
four hand they had to make the acting
bad because that would transition into
good acting after the bad but it would
have to tailor it to that delivery more
and hey you know I mean maybe the
because I because I saw Hayden
Christensen something after that and he
was really good in it so I was like what
gives listen guys if you're new to the
channel subscribe today by clicking this
button and become a reject do they mean
YouTube fans that's YouTube fans are you
having a loft
oh you're having a loss that's what I
feel like what I
they reject reason tsageri playlists of
movie reviews dank ass dubs podcast
movie inspired on this channel and let's
try to get to the shoutout
yeah let's do that
Allen Williams he puts in the real
reject shout out page click like if you
agree that SS Sniper Wolf should be a
guess in LA a few real reaction videos
um I'm looking at her I I think that she
has the wit
I think that her she has the
intelligence and the business qualities
of a woman that would be perfect to come
on this channel
come on this channel so that's a
horrible thing mister casting what you
think I could get this woman to be on my
channel she has almost 2 million
followers who [ __ ] my let's see
whatever videos are about she actually
does content I watch other people's
content a lot of Let's Plays huh göran
is so hot I never seen her channel
before well your so many hot and I want
you did you know that hey hey I'm
talking to you yeah there's so many hot
women on YouTube like so many like funny
woman and then you're like holy [ __ ]
there's like a lot of hot ass woman on
YouTube you know I just wonder does that
experience exist hey do you know for the
hottest one is Veronica 6/10 oh well
done you better Becker and brought it
back around a reach-around for me
tonight